[Music]
the show was probably going to end
the office was closed no one could go
anywhere
the coronavirus taking a devastating
toll confirmed cases now top 300 000
really very very strictly adhere to the
guidelines of physical separation
we suggest that if at all possible you
stay at home
coronavirus is exactly like having a
baby
that's exactly what it felt like when
this pandemic started
i'm not gonna lie it wasn't as bad as i
thought it was gonna be
you just stay home on lockdown trying to
survive
and you're working around the clock
to support and provide life
and i honestly
did not know what i was doing we haven't
even started the show
and
i had a very different vision and
perception
of what we wanted to accomplish with
this and it certainly did not take place
from my home
on a digital platform
i never knew we would be launching a
talk show at the
same time no one will come out to go to
a talk show
how do we get around that you'd think
that
that would be so de-incentivizing or
such a bummer um it is not
it is what is happening and you deal
with what is happening
we have an advantage in that we're
putting ourselves together
under these circumstances we're not
retrofitting for them so we should take
advantage of that
we should i took a lot of weeks of
working with
everyone on our team so closely on these
brady bunch
zooms hopefully i know it's social
distancing time so
that is incredibly challenging we might
all be here in these boxes until
eternity
so we always have to have a plan a
and a plan b um it seems like for
everything maybe even a plan c
but we never gave up we did not give in
let's surprise people with emotionality
let's not talk about how important and
intelligent you're gonna feel things in
this show
we will surprise you with like how we
are
attacking everything um
and we're also here in the way that late
night shows go hey you made it through
the day man so guess what we're gonna
put you to bed and give you a reward and
a
treat by making you laugh and talk about
the good funny stuff in life i can't
understand why we can't start the day
that way and we will
this is really high stakes for me and i
am scared
i'm scared i've like hit another wall
i know i'll find my way out of it again
i always do
you are not going to be left hanging
you're going to have what you need
you're going to have the environment you
need you're going to
have it where it needs to be whether
it's an alternate look on the set or
something that's new to another location
it's going to be where you feel good and
creative and like you can handle
this and feel proud of it i really want
to figure out
how to make this work i want to connect
with people to like
make someone's day lovely like that's it
that's the mission we're all on for this
show
i love zoom i have been saying why are
we not working
from home more hi another day
with a zoom at the top of every hour uh
yeah by the way this is my third zoom
today and it's 9am here
i feel like more people feel like
they're getting the same amount of work
done they're having connections with
people
they're being prolific things are
getting done and accomplished
talking about where we want to put
cameras and you know
how the set flow works and the design
aspects of it i am excited about people
getting their quality of life by the way
bethany i just thought that was my child
i was like
it was like she was sent here for a
drink
isn't it great if they can do something
for you just even avoiding 30 minutes of
bumper-to-bumper traffic
i hate traffic there is no question in
my mind
that hell is hot and it is
just full of traffic and
i just go bananas i lose all cool so
somehow like zoom has absolved my life
of
all of that and i can wear sweatpants
and i just love it but there is a time
and a place for zoom for sure
it's never gonna replace
what travel is meant for which is
expanding
our experiences understanding cultures
seeing different things
but for business oh my god
if we ever go back i'm never going back
i don't think we do i think we've all
had a bite of the apple
everybody gets this and business as
usual will never be the same
we need you every step of the way at
every turn you have succeeded
i loved so much the page you wrote about
how to shoot with all the details in
particulars
about how we're going to film this this
moment
has made me become someone that i never
thought
i could be let alone would be which is
someone
who sought out every technological
advancement
we have this really interesting 2020
mechanism
that i'm really thrilled to introduce
you to
one of a kind virtual audience but do
all
virtual you don't bring a hologram into
a virtual world it's like too many
layers of distance
and technology that don't even look
right i love design and so
i tried to put all of it together into
this new box that was
sort of pretty and shiny and exciting
us being ahead of the game and having a
really elevated
visual architectural design
plan and and technological functionality
uh is gonna be crucial how are we
interacting with people
how are we bringing people into this how
does it look
i really think we've got we've got the
seeds of something here so
um you know excited to see what what we
can build
you know a little bit bigger
you know than what we've originally
talked about and just excited to see
see what we can come up with
how does our production design now
become instead of you know bleachers for
all these human beings who are not going
to be there
screens i want big screens i've always
loved blade runner when you first
see whatever that place is
that ridley scott created i just think
it's so timeless and cool
and you're like okay screens are the
sizes
of buildings this is so compelling
so i said we need big screens this is
the most crude drawing
but this is the screen where like
you know said person is
is this the worst it's the worst drawing
ever
it's not my skill set and that's me
one thing i don't want to be is like
coming out like a dinosaur
like from my living room so we're gonna
figure this out we
do really good work when we're tasked to
think
differently the outcomes sometimes are
like better than if we could have
had it another way it's so impressive
it's just a total compliment to the team
if 2020 is anything there is a modernity
to this year this historical
game-changing life-altering year
so why shouldn't everything else fall
into line like that why shouldn't
everything
take a deep look inside of itself
and ask questions that
clearly we were not asking before